The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
So what we are going to do today
is go about discovering
other alternating methods.
We know you guys are amazing
hackers and you can actually
do all those things by hand.
But to make multi-core generally
acceptable, can we
do things automatically?
Can we really reduce a burden
from the programers?
So at the beginning I'm going
to talk about general
parallelizing compilers.
What people have done.
What's the state of the art.
Kind of get your feel
what is doable.
Hopefully, that will be a little
over an hour, and then
we'll go talk about StreamEd
compiler, what we have done
recently, and how this
automation part can do.
So, I'll talk a little bit
about parallel execution.
This is kind of what
you know already.
Then go into parallelizing
compilers, and talk about how
to determine if something is
parallel by doing data
dependence analysis, and how
to increase the amount of
parallelism available in
code loop, what kind of
transformation.
Then we go look at how to
generate code, because once
you see that something is
parallel, how you actually get
to run parallel.
And finish up with actually how
to do communication code
in a machine such as a server.
So in parallel execution, this
is something -- it's a review.
So there are many ways of
parallelism, things like
instruction level parallelism.
It's basically effected by
hardware or compiler
scheduling.
As of today this is
in abundance.
In all for scalars we do
that, in [OBSCURES]
we do that.
Then password parallelism,
it's what most of you
guys are doing now.
You probably find a program, you
divide it into tasks, you
get task level parallelism,
mainly by hand.
Some of you might be doing data
level parallelism and
also loop level parallelism.
That can be the hand or
compiler generated.
Then, of course, pipeline
parallelism is more mainly
done in hardware and language
extreme, do pipeline
parallelism.
Divide and conquer parallelism
we went a little bit more than
in hardware, mainly by hand
for recursive functions.
Today we are going to focus
on loop level parallelism,
particularly how do loop level
parallelism by the compiler.
So why loops?
So loops is interesting because
people observed in
morse code, 90% of execution
time is in 10% of the code.
Almost 99% of the execution time
is in 10% of the code.
This called a loop, and it makes
sense because running at
3 gigahertz, if only run one
instruction one, then you run
through the hard drive in only a
few minutes because you need
to have repeatability.
A lot of time repeatability
thing loops.
Loops, if you can parallelize,
you can get really good
performance because loops most
of the time, each loop
iteration have the same amount
of work and you get nice good
load balance, it's somewhat
easier to analyze, so that's
why the compiler start there.
Whereas if you try to get task
level parallelism, things have
a lot more complexities that
automatic compiler cannot do.
So there are two types
of parallel loops.
One is a for all loop.
That means there are no loop
carried dependences.
That means you can get the
sequential code executing, run
everything in parallel, and at
the end you have a barrier and
when everybody finishes
you continue on
the sequential code.
That is how you do
a for all loop.
Some languages, in fact, have
explicitly parallel construct,
say OK, here's a for all
loop and go do that.
The other type of
loop is called a
foracross or doacross loop.
That says OK, while the loop
is parallel, there are some
dependences.
That means some value generated
here is used
somewhere here.
So you can run it parallel,
but you have some
communication going too.
So you had to move data.
So it's not completely running
parallel, there's some
synchronization going on.
But you can get large chunk
running parallels.
So we kind of focus on dual
loops today, and let's look at
this example.
We see it's a for far
so it's a parallel
loop or for all loop.
When you know it's parallel,
in here, of course,
the user said that.
What we can do is we can
distribute the iteration by
chunking up the iteration space
into number of process
chunks, and basically
run that.
If PMD mode, you can at the
beginning the first processor
can calculate the number of
iterations you can run on each
process in here, and then you
synchronize, you put a barrier
there, so everybody kind of
sync up at that point.
Or other process of waiting, and
at that point, everybody
starts, when you reach this
point it's running, it's part
of iterations, and then you're
going to put a barrier
synchronization in place.
Kind of obvious, parallel code
basically in here, running on
shared memory machine
at this point.
So this is what we can do.
I mean this is what
we saw before.
Of course, instead of doing
that, you can also do fork
join types or once you want to
run something parallel, you
can fork a thread and each
thread gets some amount of
iterations you run, and after
that you merge together.
So you can do both.
So that's my hand.
How do you do something like
that by the compiler?
That sounds simple enough,
trivial enough.
But you don't automate
the entire process.
How to go about doing that.
So, here are some normal
loops, for loops.
So the for all does this thing
that was so simple, which is
the for all construct that means
somebody could look at
that and said this
loop is parallel.
But you look at these FOR loops,
how many of these loops
are parallel?
Is the first loop parallel?
Why?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED.]
PROFESSOR: It's a loop because
the iteration, one of that is
using what you wrote
in iteration zero.
So iteration one has to wait
until iteration zero is
done, so and so.
How about this one?
Why?
AUDIENCE: [NOISE.]
PROFESSOR: Not really.
So it's writing element
0 to 5, it's reading
elements 6 to 11.
So they don't overlap.
So what you read and what you
write never overlap, so you
can keep doing it in any order,
because the dependence
means something you wrote,
later you will read.
This doesn't happen in here.
How about this one?
AUDIENCE: There's no dependence
in there.
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED.]
PROFESSOR: So you're writing
even, you're reading odd.
So there's no overlapping
or anything like that.
Question?
OK.
So, the way to look at that --
I'm going to go a little
bit of formalism.
You can think about this
as a iteration space.
So iteration is if you look at
each iteration separately,
there could be thousands and
millions of iterations and
your compiler never [COUGHING]
doing any work, and also some
iteration space is defined by
a range like 1 to n, so you
don't even know exactly how
many iterations are
going to be there.
So you can represent this
as abstract space.
Normally, most of this
loops you look at you
normalize to step one.
So what that means is all the
integer points in that space.
So if you have a loop like
this, y equals 0 to 6, J
equals 1i to 7.
That's the iteration space,
there are two
dimensions in there.
The points that start iteration
off because it's not
a rectangular space, it can have
this structure because
j's go in triangular in here.
So the way you can represent
that is so you can represent
iteration space by a vector
i, and you can have each
dimension or use
two dimension.
This was some i1, i2
space in here.
So you can represent
it like that.
It's the notion of lexicographic
ordering.
That means if you execute the
loop, what's the order you're
going to receive this thing.
If you execute this loop,
what you are going to do
is you go from --
you go like this.
This is lexicographical
ordering of
everything in the loops.
That's the normal
execution order.
That's a sequential order.
At some point you want to make
sure that anything we do kind
of has a look and feel
of the sequential
lexicographical order.
So, one thing you can say
is if you have multiple
dimensions, if there are two
iterations, one iteration
lexicographical and another
iterations says if all outer
dimensions are the same, you
go to the first dimension
where the numbers, they are in
two different iterations.
Then that dictates if it's
lexicographical than the other.
So if the outer dimensions are
the same, that means the next
one decides, the next one
decides, next one decides
going down.
First one that's actually
different decides who's before
the other one.
So another concept is called
affine loop nest. Affine loop
nest says loop bounds are
integer linear functions of
constants, loop constant
variable
and outer loop indices.
So that means if you want to get
affine function within a
loop, that has to be a linear
function or integer function
where all the things either
has to be constant or loop
constants --
that means that that variable
doesn't change in the loop or
outer loop indices.
That makes it much easier
to analyze.
Also, array axises, each
dimension, axis function has
the same property.
So of course, there are many
programs that doesn't satisfy
this, for example,
if we do FFD.
That doesn't satisfy that
because you have
exponentials in there.
But what that means is at 50,
there's probably no way that
the compiler's going
to analyze that.
But most kind of loops fit this
kind of model and then
you can put into nice
mathematical framework and
analyze that what I'm going to
go through is kind of follow
through some of the
mathematical
framework with you guys.
So, what you can do here is if
you look at this one, instead
of representing this iteration
space by each iteration, which
can be huge or which is not even
known at compile time,
what you can do is you can
represent this by kind of a
bounding space of iterations,
basically.
So what this is, we don't mark
every box there, but we say
OK, look, if you put
these planes --
I put four planes in here, and
everything inside these planes
represent this iteration
space.
That's nice because instead of
going 0 to 6, if you go 0 to
60,000, still I have the same
equation, I don't suddenly
have 6 million data points in
here I need to represent.
So, my representation doesn't
grow with the size of my
iteration space.
It grows with the shape of
this iteration space.
If you have complicated one,
it can be difficult.
So what you can do is you can
iteration space, it's all
iterations zero to
six, j's I27.
This is all linear functionns.
That makes our analysis
easier.
So the flip side of that
is the data space.
So, if m dimension array
has m dimensional
discrete cartesian space.
Basically, in the data space you
don't have arrays that are
odd shaped.
It's almost a hypercube
always.
So something like that is a
one dimensional space and
something can be represented
as a two
dimensional space in here.
So data space has this nice
property, in that sense it's a
t multi-dimensional hypercube.
And what that gives you
is kind of a bunch of
mathematical techniques to kind
of do and at least see
some transformations we need
to do in compiling.
As humans, I think we can look
at a lot more complicated
loops by hand, and get a better
idea what's going on.
But in a compiler you need to
have a very simple way of
describing what to analyze, what
to formulate, and having
this model helps you put it into
a nice mathematical frame
you can do.
So the next thing
is dependence.
We have done that so I will go
through this fast. So the
first is a true dependence.
What that means is I wrote
something, I write it here.
So I really meant
that I actually
really use that value.
There are two dependences mainly
because we are finding
dependence on some location,
is an anti-dependence.
That means I can't write it
until this read is done
because I can't destroy
the value.
Output dependence is there, so
ordering of writing that you
need to maintain.
So in a dynamic instance, data
dependence exist between i and
j if Either i and j is a write
operation, and i and j refers
to the same variable, and
i executes before j.
So it's the same thing, one
execute before the other.
So it's not that you don't have
a dependence when they
get there in time, then it
become either true or anti.
So it's always going to
be positive over time.
So how about other accesses?
So one element, you can figure
out what happened.
So how do you do dependence
and other accesses?
Now things get a little bit
complicated, because arrays is
not one element.
So that's when you go to
dependence analysis.
So I will describe this using
bunch of examples.
So in order to look at arrays,
there are two spaces I need to
worry about.
One is the iteration space,
one is the data space.
What we want to do is figure
out what happens at every
iteration for data and what
other dependences kind of
summarize this down.
We don't want to look at, say
OK, one iteration depend on
second, two depend on third
-- you don't want to list
everything.
We need to come up
with a summary --
that's what basically dependence
analysis will do.
So if you have this access,
this is this loop.
What happens is as we run down,
so iterations we are
running down here.
So we have iteration zero,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
First do the read, write,
read, write.
So this is kind of time
going down there.
What you do is this one you are
reading and you are writing.
You're reading and writing,
so you have a
dependence like that.
You see the two anti-dependence.
Read -- anti-dependence, I have
anti-dependence going on here.
If you look at it, here's
a dependence vector.
What that means is there's a
dependence at each of those
things in there -- that's
anti-dependence going on.
One way to look at summarizes of
this, what is my iteration.
My iteration goes like --
what's my dependence.
I have anti-dependence with the
same iteration, because my
read and write has to be
dependence in the same iteration.
So this is a way to kind
of describe that.
So a different one.
This one.
I did Ai plus 1 equals Ai So
what you realize is iteration
zero, you wrote iteration zero,
you wrote a zero, you
read these and you wrote A1, and
iteration 1, you read A1
and wrote A2, basically.
Now what you have is your
dependence is like
that, going like that.
So if you look at what's
happening in here, if you
summarize in here, what you
have is a dependence going
like that in iteration space.
So in iteration that means
iteration 1 is actually these
two dependence, that uses
something that wrote iteration
zero, iteration 2 you have
something iteration 1, and you
have iteration going
like that.
Sometimes this can be summarized
as the dependence
vector of 1.
Because the previous one was
zero because there's no loop
carry dependency.
In the outer loop there's
a dependence on 1.
So if you have this one, I plus
2, of course, it gets
carried 1 across in here and
then you have a 1 skipped
representation in here.
If you have 2I2 by plus
1, what you realize
is there's no overlap.
So there's no basically
dependency.
You kind of get how that
analytic goes.
So, to find data dependence in
a loop, so there's a little
bit of legalese.
So let me try to do that.
So for every pair of array
accesses, what you want to
find is is there a dynamic
instant that happened?
An iteration that wrote a value,
and another dynamic
instance happened that later
that actually used that value.
So the first access, so there's
a dynamic instance
that's wrote, or that access,
and another iteration instance
that also accessed the
same location later.
And one of them has to
be right, otherwise
there are two in anti.
That's the notion about
the second one came
after the first one.
You can also look at
the same arrays.
It doesn't have the be the same
as different access, the
same array access if
you are writing.
If you look at same array access
writing you can have
output dependences also.
So it's basically between a read
and a write, and a write
and a write.
Two different writes, it can
be the same write too.
Key thing is we are looking
at location.
We're not looking at value path
and say who's actually in
the same location.
Loop carry dependence
means the dependence
cross a loop boundary.
That means the person who read
and person who wrote are in
different loop iteration.
If it's in the same iteration,
then it's all local, because
in my iteration I deal with
that, I moved data around.
But what I'm writing is used by
somebody else in different
iteration, I have loop carry
dependence going on.
Basic thing is there's a loop
carry dependence, that loop is
not parallelized in that.
What that means is I am writing
in one iteration of
the loop and somebody is reading
in different iteration
of the loop.
That means I actually had to
move the data across, they can
happen in parallel.
That's a very simple way
of looking at that.
So, what we have done is --
OK, the basic idea is how
to actually go and
automate this process.
The simple notion is called a
data dependence analysis, and
I will give you a formulation
of that.
So what you can formally do is
using a set of equations.
So what you want to say is
instead of two distinct
iterations, one is the
write iteration,
one is the read iteration.
One iteration writes
the value, one
iteration reads the value.
So write iteration basically,
writes a item loop plus 1, the
read iteration reads AI.
So we know both read and write
have to be within loop bound
iteration, because we know
that because we can't be
outside loop bounds.
Then we also want to make sure
that the loop carried
dependence, that means
read and write can't
be in the same iteration.
If it's in the same iteration,
I don't have loop carry
dependence.
I am looking for loop carry
dependence at this point.
Then what makes both of
the read and write
write the same location.
That means access 1 has
to be the same.
So the right access point is
iw plus 1, and read access
function is [? IEI. ?]
So the key thing is now we
have set up equation.
Are there any values for ie
and j, integer values, I'm
sorry, iw and ir that these
equations are true.
If that is the case, we can say
ah-ha, that is the case,
there's an iteration that the
write and read are writing
into two different iterations
-- one write iteration, one
read iteration, writing
to the same value.
Therefore that's a different
[OBSCURED].
Is this true?
Is there a set of values
that makes this true?
Yeah, I mean you can do ir
equals 1, iw equals 1,
and ir equals 2.
So there's a value in there so
these equations will come up
with a solution, and at that
point you have a dependency.
AUDIENCE: [NOISE]
PROFESSOR: So that's very easy
to make this formulation.
So if the indices is calculated
with some thing or
loop value, I can't write
the formulation.
So the data that I can do this
analysis is this indices has
to be the constant
or indefinite.
This is A of b of I. So if my
array is A of b of i, I don't
know how the numbers work
if you have A of b i.
I have no idea about Ai
is without knowing
values of B of i.
And B of i, I can't
summarize it.
Each B of i might be different
and I can't come up with this
nice single formulation that
can check out every B of i.
And I'm in big trouble.
This is doable, but this is
not easy to do like this.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [NOISE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
So that the interesting thing
that you're not looking at.
Because when we summarized it,
because what you are going to
do is we are trying to summarize
for everything,
every iteration, and we are not
trying to divide it into
saying OK, can I find
the parallel groups.
Yes.
You can do some more complicated
analysis and do
something like that.
Yes.
So other interesting thing is
OK, the next thing you want to
see whether can find
output dependence.
OK, are there two different
iterations that they're
fighting the same thing.
What that means is the
iterations are I1, I2, and I1
not equals I2, and I1 plus
1 equals I2 plus one.
There's no solution to this one
because the I1 has to be
equal to I2 according to this,
and I1 cannot be equal to I2
during this one.
That says OK, look, I don't have
output dependence because
it can be satisfied.
OK, so here I know I have
a loop carried --
I haven't said the two
anti depends on which
directions this is.
Two anti-dependents, but I don't
have a loop carried out
to [OBSCURED].
So how do we generalize this?
So what you can do is as integer
vector I, so in order
to generalize this, you can
use integer programming.
How many of you know integer
programming or linear
programming?
OK.
We are not going to go into
detail, but I'll tell you what
actually happen.
So integer programming says
there's a vector of variable
I, and if you have a formulation
like that, is
array, AI is less than or equal
to B, A and B are all
constant integers, and you can
use the integer programming,
you can see that there's a
solution for IE or not.
This is if you do things like
operations research, there's a
lot of work around it.
People actually want to know
what value is Y. We don't care
that much what values,
we just want to know
the solution or not.
If there's a solution, we know
that there's a dependent.
If there's no solution we know
there's no dependent.
So we need to do is we need to
get this set of equations and
put it on that form.
That's simple.
For example, what you want
is AI less than B --
that means you have constnat
A1 I1, plus A2 i2, which is
less than or equal to
B. So you won't have
this kind of a system.
Not equals doesn't really
belong there.
So the way you deal with not
equals if you do it in two
different problems. You can say
IW less than IER is one
problem, and W is greater then
IER is other problem, and if
either problem has a solution,
you have a dependence.
So that means one is true
and one is anti.
You can see the true dependence
or anti-dependence,
you can look at that.
This one is a little
bit easier.
This is less than, not
actually less than --
less than equal.
How do you deal with equal?
So the way you deal with equal
is you write in both
directions.
So if A is less than B, A less
than or equal to B, B is less
than or equal to A means
actually is equal to B. So you
can actually try two different
inequalities and get equal to
down there.
So you have to kind of massage
things a little bit in here.
So here are our original
iteration bounds, and here's
our one problem because we are
saying write happens before
read, so these are two
dependents that
we are looking at.
This is saying that write
location is the same as the
read location and this is equal,
so I have two different
equations in here.
So kind of massage this a little
bit to put it in i
form, and we can come
up with A's and B's.
These are just manual steps,
A's and B's, and now we are
going to throw it into some
super duper integer linear
program package and it will say
yes or no and your set.
And of course, you had
to do another problem
for the other side.
You can generalize it for much
more complete loop nest. So if
you have this complicated loop
nest in here, you had to solve
you've got n deepness, you have
to solve two end problems
with all these different
constraints.
I'm not going to go over this.
I have the slides in here.
So that's the single
dimension.
So how about multi-dimension
dependences?
So I have two dimensional
iteration space here, and I
have I,J equals AI, J minus 1.
That's my iteration space.
What does my dependence
look like?
We have arrows too.
Which direction are
the arrows going?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: We have something
like this.
Yup.
We have something like this
because that's J minus 1, the
I's are the same.
Of course, if you have the other
way around, go other
direction, one is anti and one
is it two dependence, so you
can figure that one out.
And do something complicated.
First one.
So IJ, I minus 1, J plus 1.
Which has to be diagonal.
Which diagonal does it go?
This way or this way?
Who says this way?
So, this is actually going
in this direction.
This is where you have to
actually think which iteration
is actually write and
read in here.
So things get complicated.
This one is even more
interesting.
This one.
There's only one dimensional
array or two dimensional loop
nest. So what that
means is who's
writing and who's reading?
If you look at it basically --
actually this actually is a
little bit wrong, because the
dependence analysis says --
actually, all these things,
all this read has to go into
all the write, because they
are writing any J, just writing
the same thing.
So this is a little bit wrong.
This is actually more
data flow analysis.
This is a different -- their
dependence means I don't care
who the guy wrote, because he's
the last guy who wrote,
but everybody's reading,
everybody else is writing the
same location.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: Keep rewriting
the same thing again
and again and again.
You start depending on --
It's not dependant on J's it's
dependant on I. But location
says you used to have iterations
right in the same
location, different J. So not
matter what J, it's writing in
the same location.
You know what I'm saying?
Because J thinks J.
AUDIENCE: [NOISE].
PROFESSOR: This is
iteration space.
I am looking at iteration.
I am looking at I and J.s
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: B is a one
dimensional array.
So B is a one dimensional
array.
So what that means is --
The reason I'm saying it's the
iteration space and array
space is a match.
I'll correct this and put it
in there because this is a
data flow diagram.
It's row independant.
This one writing to what?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: Iteration space
is I and J. So, this
is writing to what?
I zero is --
This is writing to what?
B1.
All those things are
writng to B1.
This is really --
So this is writing to B1,
this is reading B zero.
So this iteration is
reading B1 again.
So this was B1, this
is iteration B1.
So each of these is writing to
B1, each of these are reading
from B1, so each has to be
dependent from each other.
AUDIENCE: So I guess one thing
that's confusing here is why
isn't it just -- why don't we
just have arrows going down
the column?
Why do we have all these--?
PROFESSOR: Arrows going down
the column means each is
trying to do different
location.
So what happens is that
this one, arrays
going down this way.
Is this one -- what's wrote here
is only that location,
only this side I accidentally
located.
These are all writing to the
same location and reading from
the same location.
AUDIENCE: Why isn't
B iterated?
PROFESSOR: This is
iteration space.
I have two different
loops here.
AUDIENCE: But I don't understand
why B [NOISE.]
PROFESSOR: This is my program.
I can write this program.
This is a little bit of a stupid
program because I am
kind of trying to do the same
thing again and again.
But hey, my program doesn't say
array dimensions has to
match your loop dimension.
It doesn't say that so you can
have programs like that.
You can have other way too.
So the key thing is to make --
don't confuse iteration space
versus array space.
They are two different spaces,
two different number of
dimensions.
That's all the point that
I'm going to make here.
So by doing dependence analysis,
you can figure out
-- now you can formulate
this nicely --
figure out where the
loops are parallel.
So that's really neat.
The next thing I'm going to go
is trying to figure out how
you can increase the parallelism
opportunities.
Because there might be cases
where the original code you
wrote, there might be some
loops that are not
parallelizable, assays, and can
you go and increase that.
So I'm going to talk about few
different possibilities of
doing that.
Scalar privatization, I will
just go in each of these
separating.
So here is interesting
program.
To get parallel to the
temporary and use the
temporary in here.
You might not know you had
written that but the compiler
normally generates something
like that because you always
had temporaries in here,
so this might be
what compiler generate.
Is this loop parallel?
AUDIENCE: Yup.
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: Is the loop carry
dependence true or anti --
What's the true dependence
which to which?
We didn't loop true
dependence.
What is the loop carry
dependence?
Anti-dependence.
Because I cannot -- you see I
equal 1, basically wrote here
in this reading.
I can't write I equals 2x until
I equals 1 is done and
done reading that.
I have one location and
everybody's trying to read or
write that, even though I
don't really use data.
This is the sad thing
about this.
That I'm really using this
guy's data, but I'm just
waiting for the same
space to occupy.
So, there's a loop carry
dependence in here, and it's
anti-dependent.
So what you can do is if you
find any anti or output loop
carry dependence, you
can get rid of them.
I'm not really using that value,
I'm just keeping a
location in here.
So how can we get rid of that?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's one thing.
There's two ways of doing it.
One is I assign something
local.
So each processor will
have its own copy,
so I don't do that.
So it's something like this,
so that's [OBSCURED].
Or I can look at the array.
In the array you can have either
number of process or
iterations for each iteration.
But uses a different location.
This is more efficient than
this one because we are
touching lot more locations
in here.
I haven't done one thing here.
I'm not complete.
What have I forgotten to
do in both of these?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because it was
beforehand somebody might
use final assignment of the loop
nest, so what you had to
do is you had to kind
of finalize x.
Because I had a temporary
variable, so with n, the last
value has to go into x.
You can't keep just not
calculating value in something.
So in here, also, you just
say last value is x.
But after you do that, basically
now each of this
loop is faster.
Everybody go that?
OK, here's another example.
x equals x plus AI.
Do I have loop carry
dependent?
What did the loop-carried
dependence?
True or anti?
True dependence.
So this guy is actually creating
previous value and
adding something in the event.
So of course in true dependence
I cannot seem to
parallelize.
But there are some interesting
things we can do.
That was an associative
operation.
I didn't care which order this
initial happened, so I'm just
keeping a lean bunch
of values in here.
And the results were never
used in the other loop.
So we just keep adding things
and at the end of the loop you
get the sum total in here.
I never used any kind of partial
values anywhere.
So that gives the idea.
So what you can do is we can
translate this into each of
the guys doing a temporary
addition
into its own variable.
So each processor, just
do a partial sum.
At the end, once they're done,
you basically do the full sum.
Of course, you can do a tree
or whatever much more
complicated thing then that --
you can also parallelize this
part at the tree addition.
But you can do that.
I mean Roderick talked about
this in hand parallelization.
But we are doing something
very simple in here.
So these compilers can figure
out associative
operations and do that.
So this is where all the
people who are in
parallelizing, and all the
people who are writing this
scientific code kind of start
having arguments.
Because they say oh my God,
you're doing operations and
it's going to have numerical
stability issues.
Yes all true.
In compilers you have these
flags that say OK, just forget
about all these very issues, and
most probably it will be
right, and in most code
it will work.
You might find that problem,
too -- you change operation
order to get some parallelism
and suddenly you are running
unstability.
There are some algorithms that
you can't do that, but most
algorithms you can.
So here's another interesting
thing.
So, I have a program like that,
2 to the power I, and of
course, most of the time
exponentiation is very expensive.
If you have a smart
compiler --
I don't have to exponentiate.
This thing called strength
reduction.
They say wait a minute --
I will keep variable t.
This 2 to the power i means
basically every time I
multiply it by 2 and I can't
keep repeating that.
Do you see why these two
are equal there?
This is good.
A lot of good compilers
do that.
But now what did
I suddenly do?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED.]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I reduced the
amount of computation,
obviously, but I just introduce
a loop-carried true
dependence here.
Because now I have t dependent
on the previous t to calculate
the next value, and while
order-wise or sequential-wise
this is a win, now suddenly
I can't parallelize.
Of course, a lot of times what
you had to do is you have a
very smart programmer.
They say aha, I know this
operation is expensive so I am
going to do this myself and
create you a much simpler
program in sequentially.
Then you try to parallelizes
this and you can't.
So what you might try to do is
kind of do this direction
transformation many times to
make the program run a little
bit slower sequentially just
so you can actually go and
parallelize it.
So this get's a little
bit counterintuitive.
You just look at a program and
say yeah there is a loop
carried dependence, I can do it
a little bit more expensive
without the loop carried
dependence, and then suddenly
my loop is parallelized.
So there might be cases where
you might have to do it by
hand, and a lot of compilers
automatic parallelizing
compilers, try to
do this also.
Kind of look at these kind
of things and try to
move in that direction.
Whereas, most of the sequential
compiler is trying
to find this and move
this direction.
So, OK I said that.
So, another thing called
array privatization.
So scalars, I show you where
when you have anti and output
dependence on a variable,
you need to privatize.
And in arrays, you have
a lot more complexity.
I'm not going to go into that,
you can actually do private
copies also in there.
You can do bunch of
transformation.
Another thing people do is
called interprocedural
parallelization.
So the thing is you have a
nice loop and you start
analyzing loop and in the middle
of a loop you have a
function call.
Suddenly what are you
going to do with it?
You have no idea what the
function does, and most of the
simple analysis says OK, I can't
parallelize anything
that has a function call.
That's not a good parallelizing
compiler because
a lot of loops have function
calls and you might call it
something simple as sine
function or some simple
exponentiation function and
then suddenly it's not
parallelizable.
This is a big problem.
There are two things
you can do.
One is interprocedural analysis
and another inlining.
So the interprocedural analysis
says I'm going to
analyze the entire program and
I have function, I'm going to
go and try to analyze the
function itself also.
What happens is -- so assume
if the functions are used
many, many times, so fine
function might be used
hundreds of time.
So every time you have a call
of a sine function, if you
keep analyzing, reanalyzing
what's happening inside of the
sine function, you kind of
have exponential blow up.
So if you code size n, you might
have an exponential time
of a number of lines that need
to be analyzed because every
call need to go there, call some
other functions, you can
see the blow up.
And so analysis might
be expensive.
Other option is you analyze
each function once.
Yeah, OK.
I analyze this function once
and every time I use that
function I just use that
analysis information.
What that means is you have a
kind of summary of what that
function does for every call.
This is not that easy and this
runs into a thing called
unrealizable part problem,
because you go into function
in one part --
assume you call foo from
here and return here.
You call it here and
return and here.
So when you analyze, normally
you can go from here to here,
here to here, but if you treat
foo as only one thing you
might be able to even think that
you can go here to here
and here to here.
So this looks like one
thing in here.
You see that control here goes
here, comes here do a function
call goes here, because
we are not treating
this as separate instance.
So why did are we analyzing
it once?
This cleared all this additional
mess and then can
have problems in here.
So these are the kind of
researchy things people are
working on.
There's no perfect answer,
these are complicated
problems, so you had to do some
interesting balance in here.
Because other thing is every
analyst has to deal with that,
so you had to kind of
an anti-compiler,
which is not simple.
Inlining is much more easy.
It's a poor man solution, so
every time you have function
call, you just bring
the function and
just copy it in there.
And every time you have function
call you bring the
function and you can run it
through the same compiler, but
of course, you can have
huge code blow up.
It's not only analysis expense,
you might have a
function that before had only
100 lines, now we have
millions of lines in there
and then try and do cache
problems, all those
other issues.
So can be very expensive too.
So what people do is things like
selective inlining and a
lot of kind of interesting
combinations of these.
Finally, loop transformations.
So i have this loop, so I have
Aij equals Aij minus 1, A i
minus 1 j So look at my -- my
arrowheads look too big there,
but look at my dependences.
Is any of this parallel?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED.]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So, assays neither --
you can't parallelize I because
there's a loop carry
dependence in I dimension.
You can't parallelize J because
there's loop carry
dependence in J diimension.
She has idea because you
can actually pipeline.
So pipelining, we haven't
figured out how
to parallelize pipeline.
So the way you can do
this simply is a
thing called loop skewing.
You can kind of --
because iteration space has
changed from a data space.
You can come up with a new
iteration space that kind of
skew the loop in there.
So what it does is normally
iteration space, what this J
outside, so you go execute
like this.
The skill that -- loop basically
say I am executing
this way, so I'm executing
the pipeline,
basically pipeline here.
So I'm kind of going like this
way, executing that way.
If I could run that loop in that
fashion, what I can do is
I can run this -- after this
iteration, when you go run the
next iteration, there's no
dependence across here.
If I run here, I don't have
dependence, so I can run each
of these and I have a parallel
set of iterations to run.
So in here, what happens is
this inner loop it can be
parallel, basically like your
pipeline, but it's written in
a way that I still have my two
loops in here, but I have done
this weird transformation.
Another interesting is
granularity of parallelism.
Assume I have a loop
like that, i and j.
Which loop is that in here?
i or j?
j is parallel.
OK, I do something like that.
I say I run i, every iteration
I do a barrier, I run j
parallel and I end up doing
a barrier again.
What might be a problem in
something like this?
I mean inner parallelism can
be expensive, because every
time I had to do this probably
expensive barrier, run a few
iterations, a few in
this one, probably
only like a few cycles.
And write this very expensive
barrier again, and everybody
communicates --
all of those things.
Most of the time when you do
inner loop parallelism it
actually slows down
the program.
You will probably find it too
sometimes, if you define the
parallelism inner array to be
too small, it actually has a
negative impact, because all the
communication you need to
do, synchronization you
need to do all of
them out of the program.
So inner loop is expensive.
What are your choices?
Don't parallelize.
Pretty good choice for
a lot of cases.
You look at this and this is
actually going to win you
basically by doing that.
Or can you transform it to
outer loop parallelism.
Take inner loop parallelism and
you change it to get outer
loop parallelism.
This program is actually nice,
there are some complex
analysis you need to do to
make sure that's legal.
So you can basically
take this one and
transform in other direction.
What that means is kind of
do a loop interchange.
So now instead of i, you have a
a j outer dimension, i inner
dimension, inner loop.
When you do that what you have
is your barrier, and then you
can run this is parallel
and this like this.
Suddenly, instead of having n
barriers for that loop, you
have only one barrier.
Suddenly you have a much larger
chunk you're running,
and this can be run.
OK, so this is great.
So I talked to all about all
this nice transformation,
stuff like that.
So at some point when you know
something is parallel you
might want to go and generate
parallel form.
So the problem is, depending on
how you partition, the loop
bound has to be changed, and I'm
going to talk to you about
how to get loop bound.
So let's look at this program.
So I have something in here and
there's an inner loop that
actually reads, outer
loop writes.
Inner loop reads.
And it's a triangular thing.
It's a big mess.
Now I assume I want to run
the i loop parallel.
So what that means is I want
to run the first process --
there is no for this one, this
one on one iteration, two
iteration, three, four,
whatever, each one's in here.
How do I actually go about
generating code that
actually does that?
Each processor runs its right
number of iteration.
This is a non-trivial thing
because triangularly you get
something different and you
can assume all this
complexity.
One thing I did is my iteration
space between i and
j, this is my iteration space.
So I assume, assume I am
running a processor.
Each I iteration run by your
processor, you can say you
have then another dimension P,
and say i equals P. So I can
look at now instead of a two
dimensional space in a three
dimensional space.
So in this analysis, if you can
think multi-dimensionally
it's actually very helpful
because we can kind of keep
adding dimensions in here.
So what are the loop
bounds in here?
What we can do is use another
technique called
Fourier-Motzkin Elimination to
calculate loop bounds by using
projections of the
iteration space.
I will go through later
a bit to give you a
flavor for what it is.
It's also, if you are in to
linear programming, this is
kind of extension techniques
on that.
So the way we look
at that is --
A little bit too far.
I didn't realize MAC
can be this slow.
[ASIDE CONVERSATION]
See this is why we need
parallelism if you think this
running fast. So what you can do
is you can think about this
as this three dimensional
space.
i, j and p.
And because i is equal to p, if
you get i and p, get a line
in that dimension and
then j goes there.
So this is the kind of iteration
space in here, and
that represents inequalities
here.
So what I want is a loop where
outer dimension is p, then the
next dimension is i and j.
We can think about
it like that.
So what that means is I need to
get my iteration ordering
-- when it happens, you
just go like that.
All right, about doing that.
So this is the kind of loop I
want to generate -- let me go
and show you how we
generate that.
So here's my space in here, so
first one I want to do is my
inner most dimension is j.
And what I can do is I can look
at this thing and say
what are the bounds of j.
So, for each of the bounds of
j can be described by --
with p and i.
I'll actually show you how to
do that in little while.
Then I will get j goes
from 1 to i minus 1.
Then after that I can basically
project it into to
eliminate j dimension.
So what I'm doing is I'm going
to have a three dimension and
I project into two dimensions
without j anymore, because now
all I have left is i p and I get
a line in that dimension.
Then what I have to do is
now I had to find i.
What are my bounds of i?
And bounds of i is actually
i is equal to p.
You can figure that
one out because
there's a line in there.
Then you eliminate i and
now you get this one.
Then what are bounds of p? p
goes from basically 2 to n.
You just basically get that.
So you can do this projection in
here -- let me go in there,
and now what you end up doing
is you can get this, and of
course, outer loop p is not
a true -- like a loop.
You can say you get p, my_pid.
p is with this range.
i equals p.
Do this one.
So this one, -- generated
that piece of code.
So I will go a little bit
detail and show how this
happens, pretty much
can happen.
So I have my little bit
of different space.
I'm doing a different
projection.
I'm doing i, j, p.
I want to predict first i of a,
j of a, and p of a instead
of j, i, p before
I do anything.
So here's my iteration
space, what do I do?
The first thing I do is I find
the bounds of i, So I have
this thing.
I just basically expanded this,
and eliminated the j
this one doesn't contribute
to the bounds of i,
but everybody else.
So there are a bunch of things
that i has to be less than
that and i have to be greater
than these two.
Then what I have is bound of i
is, it has to be maximum of
this because it has to be
greater than all three.
So it has to be max of
this, this, and this.
It has to be less than these
two, it has to be
mean of this one.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Well why did you have
to go through all this.
At least in this case, the outer
loop was very simple,
you could have just directly
mapped that.
PROFESSOR: I agree with you,
it's very simple thing, but
the problem is that's because
you are smart and you can
think a little bit ahead in
there, and if I'm programming
a computer, I can't say find
these special cases.
So I want to come up with a
mathematical way that is a
bullet proof way that will work
from the simplest one to
very complicated, like for
example, finding the loop
bounds for that loop transpose
that I showed you before --
no, the skew that what
we called before.
AUDIENCE: So it's not so much
just defining an index to
iterate on, it's to
find the best
index to map, to parellize.
PROFESSOR: Any could be issue,
because you have --
for example, if the inner
dimension depends on i, and i
goes outside, then I can't
make it depend on i.
So if I have something like for
i equals something, for j
equals i to something.
Now if I switch these
two I have 4j.
I can't say it's
i to something.
I have to get rid of i and I
have to figure out in the for
i, this has to be something
with j, with some function
with j in here.
So what is this function,
how do you get that?
You need this kind of
transformations do that.
Next time I'll talk to you about
can you do it a little
bit even better.
So I get this bound in here.
Then actually you found this
is going from p to p.
So I can actually set p because,
mean and max in here.
Then after you do that, what you
have to do is eliminate I.
The way you eliminate I is you
take this has to be always
less than n and less than p.
So you take this n constraints
here and you get a n times m
constraints tier in here.
So the first three has to be
less than n, again, we repeat
it again, has to
be less than p.
Then, of course, the missing
constraint that 1
is less than j.
You put all those constraints
together.
Now, nice think is in that
one, it's still legal, it
still represents that
space, but you don't
have i there anymore.
You can completely
get rid of i.
So, by doing that -- and then
of course, there's a lot of
redundancy in here, and then you
can do some analysis and
eliminate redundancy and you
end up in this set of
constraints.
That's where when you say what's
the best, you can be
best -- it has to be correct or
that means you can't have
additional iterations
or less iterations.
But best depends on how
complicated is the loop bound
calculation.
You can come up with a correct
solution, and the best is
depending on which order
you do that.
When you have two redundant
thing, which one you
eliminate, so you can have a lot
of heuristics saying OK,
look if this one looks harder
to calculate, eliminate that
one with the other one.
So you get this set
of constraints.
Then you have to do is now
find the bounds of j.
So you have this set again.
To find a bound of j only two
constraints are there, and you
know j goes to 1 to p minus 1,
and you find the bound of j.
Getting rid of j means
there's only two.
One get rid of p minus 1.
There are two left for p.
You put it there, and then you
can eliminate the redundance
in here, and now you can find
the bounds of p which goes
from 2 to n.
And suddenly you have the loop
nest. So now I actually di
parallelization and a loop
transpose in here.
I could combine those two, use
this simple mathematical way
and find loop bounds in here.
So, I'm going to give you
something even a little bit
interesting beyond that, which
is communication code
generation.
So if you are dealing with a
cache coherent shared memory
machine, you are done.
You generate code for parallel
loop nest, you can go home
because everything else will
be done automatically.
But as we all know in something
like Cell, if you
have a no cache coherent shared
memory or distributed
memory, you have to do this
one first. Then you write
identify communication
and then you generate
communication code.
This have additional
burden in here.
So until now in data dependence
analysis, what we
looked at was location-centric
dependences.
Which location is written by
processor one is used by
processor two.
That's kind of a
location-centric kind of view.
How about if multiple writes
the same location?
We show that in example, if
multiple people write the same
location, which one
should I use?
That's not clear.
What you are using in the last
last guy who wrote that
location before I read that
thing, and that's not in these
data flow analysis.
No data dependence analysis
doesn't get it.
What you want is something
of a value-centric.
Who was the last write
before my iteration,
who wrote that location?
If I know the last write, he's
the one I should be getting
the value from.
If the last write happened in
the same processor, I am set
because I wrote the local
copy and I don't need
to deal with anything.
If the last write happened in
a different processor, you
need to get that value from the
guys who wrote it and say,
OK, you wrote that value,
give it to me.
If nobody wrote it and I'm
reading it, that means the
value came from the original
array because nobody had
written it in my iteration.
Then I'm reading something
that has come from the
previous iteration.
So I have to get it from
the original array.
But I have these three
different conditions.
So you know to represent that.
I'm not going to go into detail
on into detail on this
representation called
Last Write Trees.
So what it says is in this kind
of a loop nest in here,
you have some read access and
write accesses in here, and if
you look at it
location-centrically you get
this entire complex graph,
because this is the graph that
should have been in that example
we gave. So these
arrays going in here.
I'm switching notation.
before i was going the other
way around. j was in here.
But if you go look
at value-centric,
this is what happens.
So you say all these
guys basically got
the value from outside.
Nobody wrote it.
This got from -- this is the
write, this is the last write,
this is the last write --
I actually have my last
write information.
So where to look at that is
there are some part of
iteration got value from
somewhere, other part go
somewhere else.
You can't kind of do a big
summary, as you point out that
kind of dependence depend on
where the iterations are.
So you can represent it using
a tree when it shows up.
So you can say if j greater
than 1, here's the
relationship between
reads and writes.
Otherwise relationship means
it came from outside.
So I can say for each
different places.
So you can think about this
tree can be a lot more
complicated tree.
So each part of the iteration
space, I got data from
somewhere else.
So, you get this
function here.
I think I'll go to
the next slide.
So what you can do is now I
have processor who read,
processor who write, and
iterations that I can reading
and writing.
One thing I can do is I can
represent i using a huge
multi-dimensional space.
So what happens in here is the
receive iterations, those are
the iterations that actually
data has to be received in
communication.
Assume that the part I'm
actually communicating is also
within the loop bound,
so I can write that.
And the last write relation
is that i
send has to be i receive.
We know that.
What you have is the parallel
with the processors -- this is
i iterations are parallel, so
processor, receive processor,
is running iteration
i, process i.
Send iterations are the same
because you want to
parallelize that
loop basically.
In each iteration get assigned
to each process.
Of course, you want to make sure
the process communication
is non-local.
If it's local I don't have
loop communication.
I can represent this as this
gigantic system of equalities.
It has one, two, three, four,
five, and there's a j receiver
also in here, because you've
got to remember I think the
program I wrote, the original
program basically, write
happen in outer loop and the
read happen inner loop.
So there's only j receive,
the i send in here.
I'll show that later.
So I have five dimensions.
So I can't really draw five
dimensions, but can I wait
until it comes back?
So what I have here is I have
this set of complete system of
inequalities for receive
and in communication.
Of course, since I can't draw
five dimensions, and these
dimensions are the same, I just
wrote it in the same.
So you can actually assume
that there's another two
dimensions for this
one, and that's a
line in that dimension.
Actually, this is wrong.
Sorry.
This should be xi
here written.
My program is wrong, sorry.
Now what do I do?
One more time it has to go.
It makes me slow down my
lectures which is probably a
good thing.
There we go.
So what you can do is you can
just scan these by predicting
different ways to calculate the
send loop nest and receive
loop nest. So if you scan in
that direction, what you end
up is something saying for this
processor you need to
send, for this iteration,
this processor.
For what you need to send will
be received by these
processors and this iteration
and this, and this you can
send xi to this iteration
at this processor.
Because you had that
relationship, you can get the
loop nest that actually
will do the send.
The send there you can actually
get a loop nest do
receive and it shows up.
So what that means is, so all
these guys have to send all
these iterations have
to do the receive.
So, if you predicted a different
ordering, what you
end up is you can say now for
this processor has to receive.
All these processors had to
receive something send by
these guys.
So now you can get that entire
loop nest for receiving and
entire loop nest for sending,
and you have
computation loop nest also.
The problem is you can't run
them sequentially because
you're run in some
into the order.
So what you have is something
that next slide will show.
So you have this iteration,
there's some computation
happen from all the one, and I
will get a loop nest do some
send, I need loop nest do some
receive, in a one dimensional,
these kind of, you get three
seperate things.
But of course, what you
had to do is you
had to generate code.
So the way to do that is --.
So what you have to do is kind
of break this apart into
pieces where things happen, so
this one you do computation,
this one you do computation and
receive, and computation
send receive and whatever.
Should be probably send here
and receive but --
For that one, if you combine
this you get a complicated
mess like this.
But this all can be done very
in an automated fashion by
using this Fourier-Motzkin
Elimination and this linear
representation.
Of course, you can do
a lot of interesting
things on top of that.
You can eliminate redundant
communication, if you're
keeping sending the same thing
again that have a send unit,
eliminate that, you can
aggregate communication.
You want to send a word at a
time, you can send bunch of
things into one packet.
You can do multitask.
So same thing, send to
multiple people.
Doesn't have that much in Cell,
but assume some machines
have multitask support, you can
do that, and also you can
do some local memory management
because if you have
distributed memory, you don't
have to allocate everybody's
memory and only use a part.
You can say OK, look everybody
only had to
allocate that part.
OK.
In summary, I think automatic
parallelism of loops and
arrays -- we talked about data
dependence analysis, and we
talked about iteration and data
spaces, a how to do that,
and how the formulate assay
integer programming problem.
We can look at lot of
optimization that can increase
parallelism and then do that.
Also, we can deal with tings
like communication code
generation and generating
loop nest by doing this
Fourier-Motzkin Elimination.
So what I want to show out of
this talk is that, in fact,
this parallelization --
automatic parallelization of
normal loop can be done by
mapping into some nice
mathematical framework,
and basically
manipulating in that map.
So there are many other things
that really complicates the
life take out of parallelizing
programs. So like C, there are
pointers, you have to
deal with that.
So this problem is not this
simple, but what compiler
writers try to do most of the
time is trying to find this
kind of thing.
Find interesting mathematical
models and do a mapping in
there and then operating that
model and hopefully you can
get the analysis needed and even
the transformation needed
using that kind of
a nice model.
So I just kind of gave you
a good feel for general
parallelizing compilers.
We will take a ten-minute break
and talk about streaming.
We'll see if I can make
this computer run
faster in the meantime.